deadly outbreaks throughout history may
offer some important lessons on how we
can deal with the corona virus pandemic
about a decade ago the h1n1 swine flu
killed more than 12,000 Americans and
hospitalized more than two hundred and
seventy four thousand in the u.s. the
death toll from a 1968 flu pandemic in
the u.s. is thought to be one hundred
thousand most of them older adults the
most severe pandemic in modern history
happened in 1918 when flu infected about
one-third of the world's population it
killed an estimated six hundred and
seventy five thousand people in the US
alone in her best-selling book
leadership in turbulent times pulitzer
prize-winning author Doris Kearns
Goodwin examines how four u.s.
presidents grappled with historic
challenges and she joins us now from
Boston Doris good morning to you good
morning to you I tell you we all know
right now that we are living through
something historic and what I've been
waiting for listening for is that moment
when some leader steps forward and has a
kind of Churchill or Kennedy or
Reaganesque moment where they inspire
the world with their words
what can leaders do to strike that tone
and be kind of a coach for people as
they come together and make sacrifices
you know I think FDR presents the best
example because when he took over during
his inauguration the country was at
rock-bottom economically one out of four
out of jobs homeless people wandering
the streets banks had collapsed you
couldn't even get your money out of the
banks so what he does is to start off
saying this is pre-eminently a time to
tell the truth only a foolish optimist
would deny the dark realities at the
moment but then the only thing to fear
is fear itself and he explains as long
as leadership takes hold and we had
failed leadership before that time as
long as the country comes together he
will ask for the powers as if we were at
a war and he promised that he would take
that gift of leadership and move us
forward that one night it changed
people's feelings and then of course he
sets together an emergency Banking Act
he sets together the hundred days and he
gives jobs to people and he unemployment
insurance and he treats it as a war in
the economic system began to rebound
it's an extraordinary case that we
should remember with great hope right
now I think
we keep hearing that this is
unprecedented doors can you think of
things in the past that might give her
some comfort to say listen we've been
here before where lives have been this
disrupted yeah I think that most
disruption that's in recent history
would be World War two I mean think of
what it was like for those people who
had suddenly to raishin all sorts of
items so gasoline was rationed you
couldn't drive pleasure driving anymore
in the automobile had become you know a
moment of independence only essential
war workers could get the kind of cards
that need the gasoline at the same time
food was rationed who had stamps that
allowed you to get either food or shoes
or clothing the hardest one evidently
they said was when they rationed coffee
once one cup a day because it was coming
from Latin America and the ships
couldn't be used to take it here but
they took it in stride after a while and
it prevented price gouging and it
prevented hoarding but the most
important thing was Roosevelt understood
that he had to talk to people about why
we were sacrificing and what the end
result would be and they did it then in
good spirit and he even called for
rubber drives when we were in shortage
of rubber asking people bring in old
rubber girdles bring in old rubber toys
forty tons of rubber were brought to
village greens and it meant that the
citizens felt they were part of it which
is such an important important motion in
this thing right now if we're going to
get through this together
Doris a crisis like this can really come
to define a presidency candidate without
a question I mean think about the
leaders who are the top in historical
rankings George Washington Abraham
Lincoln and Franklin Roosevelt each one
faced a crisis of the revolution the
Civil War World War two and the
depression and each one used their
leadership qualities their own personal
qualities of empathy and understanding
and moving forward and acknowledging
mistakes and experimenting and
communicating in a way that was
trustworthy and they're remembered as
our best presidents but at the same time
a crisis can allow you to fail Buchanan
who made things worse in the 1850s is
considered probably the lowest among our
presidential leaders and Herbert Herbert
Hoover was unable to use the federal
government's resources to deal with the
depression until the very end so it was
left to the states and the localities
and it simply wasn't enough so he's now
near the bottom
the list of the presidents so gives you
opportunity for greatness but also for
failure oh do you see a silver lining
quickly doors here I do I mean I think
if we look back at history and we
remember that the people who lived in
those early days of the civil war or the
Great Depression they did not know how
it was going to end there was an
enormous anxiety and yet history tells
us that each one of those situations the
leaders came through the citizens came
through and we really did emerge
stronger than ever before history
provides solace and perspective it's why
I love it so much I think we'd go back
and remember these things yeah even
that's that's important it's comforting
to see you Doris Kearns thank you so
much for joining us Doris Kearns Goodwin